these [ __ ] aren't taking me out
who the [ __ ] are they
to take me out
they come over
they fly
our [ __ ] planes into our buildings
and kill
thousands of people
and i'm coming over there
and they're they're about to kill me
[ __ ] that
all right nick
nick where'd you grow up where are you
from originally uh right outside boston
mass
i moved all over as a kid
what kind of family you had
i had a very good family i
i'd like to say i'm blessed
i
i don't know how else to put it yet mom
and dad
my father uh
was a very hard worker he uh
instituted that into us at a very young
age
he was in construction he built houses
and he
i have two younger brothers as well and
uh
he brought us to every house he built
and uh from the ground up
he taught us
from the site work to the frame to the
finish work
and he really instituted the importance
in
hard work
and
to this day i thank him for that
what kind of kid were you in high school
uh
i'd like to say i was a jock
um
it's kind of weird actually because
being i was a marine
every single sport i played i was
defense
um i kind of
fit right into that groove
as
us defenders like to call it a seat at
the table middle linebacker nose tackle
uh for football at least and then uh
lacrosse i was defense as well
um
and uh i dabbled in a little bit of
baseball but uh
i was a catcher
but uh that didn't really get past high
school
um
yeah i had a i had a good childhood
that's great
and then military how did that come
about
so
i don't want to
say the same thing everyone else does
but
9 11 hit us
no pun intended but
i remember i was in sixth grade and no
one knew the [ __ ] what was going on um
we heard
probably five six different stories
about
what what happened and uh
it really just resonated that someone
hit us on our own turf
and uh
it was
it was time someone did something about
it
and
and as i said i was in sixth grade that
that stuck with me and i remember
telling it to my father
and
he was just not about it um
he knew we were
in a time of war
and
he worked very hard to try to
get us into college you know and uh we
you know we came from nothing
and
he really came from nothing as well and
he just worked his balls off to to try
to get us to go to college so we could
be successful and we could we could
ultimately have a good life that's
at the end of the day that's what he
wanted
he wanted us to be happy
and uh
i think he just had three boys so we
could take care of him at the end of the
day he always jokes that uh
we'll be changing his depends when he
gets older but um
yeah so
i
i think it was 1516.
i got into a little bit of trouble i
don't remember exactly what it was but i
was always kind of a fighter
and um
i
joined a program called the young
marines
and it was kind of like an rotc program
a few my buddies joined as well and uh
that really
sealed the deal for me
it was going to be the marines
the
tip of the spear
the guys on the front lines that's
that's
that's what i wanted to do
and at the age of 17
i
by myself no one else
i somehow
connected with a recruiter
told them what i wanted to do
and uh
i pretty much
got to the point where i was about to
leave and
my father
ganked it and he said if you're gonna do
it it's going to be 18.
you know and uh from 17 to 18
he tried his absolute hardest to
convince me not to do it i mean i think
ultimately he was scared
and
didn't want to lose his son he didn't
want to lose his son period
my father's not someone that gets scared
and i'm sure everyone has that
feeling about their father um
but
it was different with him um that's the
first time i saw
my dad show
any kind of emotion really
and it
it definitely affected me
but
there was something inside of me that
always just told me that
the marines was it for me
and uh
18 i signed the papers and i
went to maps
got cleared on the medical side and
right after i graduated high school i
was i was gone
do you think there's something in your
makeup your personality that just
you're meant to be a marine
uh
not everybody can enlist and that's true
but i don't know i don't want to
i don't know how to answer that but
i know
that it was for me
there you go
and uh i completely embodied it
you know i said i was in sports i would
i was a knock around guy
you know i was
never really good at the skill side of
sports but i could pop
i could lay a hit and you didn't want to
come to my side of the field period
but that kind of stuck with me and
not to toot my own horn or anything but
i did good
and
yeah i went to boot camp and
definitely a culture shock um i
did something called the buddy program
you may have heard of it
but i
i don't really have a good story about
why i joined or anything i was literally
at a house party
and uh honestly it was kind of it was
like i think it was two weeks out
from uh
going to actual boot camp
and uh
my best friend
just randomly showed up at this house
party and um
he uh sat down next to me and he's like
he's like nikki uh
what's your plans for uh you know after
high school cause um
i don't think college is gonna work out
for me and uh
i told him i was like hey mike you know
i'm this is what i'm doing
and he's like really uh well you know
what
who's car we gonna take
and uh
yeah we did it together
and um
[Music]
i gotta say
i was
absolutely relieved that i had something
something to go with especially him
i was nervous as hell
but yeah mike went with me
and to this day i appreciate that
he's always uh been the type of guy to
to the stays always have my back and i
gotta tip my hat to that kid um
mike i appreciate you
um i was actually his best man at his
wedding um
but that's getting off track but um
yeah so we went to boot camp and uh
as i said it was a culture shock but um
[Music]
in boot camp everyone has a a job and me
and mike uh were the window cleaners
and uh
when you're at window cleaner
i was with uh
first battalion alpha company and we
overlooked the parade deck and uh the
prairie deck is where everyone graduates
so every morning we are washing windows
seeing everyone graduate and we're in
our first couple weeks of boot camp
getting absolutely slayed
and mikey looks at me and he's like hey
you know nick maybe we uh
shot the gun a little too early i don't
know if uh this was the greatest
decision but uh
i always calmed down and uh
we found a way to make it work
but um
[Music]
something that sticks in my head about
boot camp uh probably
everyone says in boot camp that you know
the drill instructors that
that taught them or trained them were
cream of the crop the toughest guys
around but
i wish i could show you the absolute
demons that
trained us in boot camp because
they were guys that
had been the first ones in to uh
fallujah
in iraq
and
baghdad as well
and
those guys were absolute different breed
of marine
at that time
[Music]
i remember they always told us the story
that uh
before they went into the the cities the
the air force dropped flyers that
basically said and it was either pashtun
or dari which is
the two different dialects of what they
speak over there
uh
anything moving is dead
um if you don't get out by this date
and uh yeah they call them store
stormtroopers
anything that move was shot killed
bagged and tagged
and those were the guys training us
there was uh
one who was a kill hat there's a
kill hats are just the guys that
absolutely
break you down to nothing and build you
up into the man they want you to be
and uh
i remember hating this guy his name was
staff sergeant chambers
but he was an absolute
animal stud of a marine and uh
we
this kind of shows you i mean i guess
nowadays they would consider this hazing
but
we didn't do it again whatever it was
that uh
he was hitting us with
but uh
we had mail call
and anytime mail comes around whether
you're in boot camp you're deployed
you're in country
it's like
it's a big deal
and uh
we had a keg party before we went to
boot camp
and this was back when instagram wasn't
around uh iphones weren't around
and uh
we just had the polaroid pictures
and
there were some uh
suspect pictures to say the least of us
you know
doing keg stands just having a good time
before we left for boot camp
in boot camp you're only allowed to look
at mail at certain times and
pictures are highly discouraged
so
mike got his mail and he saw the
pictures and he hits me he's like nikki
he's like let's go take a look at these
and at the time the only time you got a
little bit of privacy
privacy
was uh
to go hit the head and
the bathrooms and boot camp
were
open stalls so you literally just had to
sit on a toilet
take your [ __ ] off and go to the
bathroom
so
me and mike sat next to each other and
we're going through the pictures
unfortunately uh
staff sergeant chambers had uh noticed
both of us going to the bathroom
together which is a no-no
and
he followed us in and he saw that we
were looking at pictures which was not
allowed
and
we were going to the bathroom sitting
down going to the bathroom taking a
number two
and um
he comes in he starts ripping us a new
one and he says uh stand up position of
attention now
and we get nothing on so we stand up
[ __ ] twigs and berries out
at the position of attention and uh
what are you guys doing bob
he
takes his finger
goes in the toilet
and takes a scoop of whatever was in the
toilet
and he puts it on our foreheads
and he says uh
to mike he's like what's that make you
private or abagast
and he was kind of confused he was like
what
what's that naked
and uh
i piped up i was like [ __ ] sir did i
ask you back and forth back and forth
regardless we had to go
throughout the rest of the day with that
on our foreheads and from then on we
were private [ __ ]
and uh
yeah that was uh that was boot camp
and now that's probably frowned upon
but uh
they brought us
down
down low and made us into
absolute killing machines
and
that's kind of harsh saying that but i
gotta say i thank that man today
uh he got me ready for the real world
maybe not in that
instance with that but
he got me ready
and i'm happy that
i had him as a drill instructor
um
and if he's out there right now i just
want to say thank you
staff sergeant chambers gunny chambers
whatever you are
you're an absolute stud
thank you
you absolutely got me ready for
afghanistan
so
the marine corps is a blur after boot
camp everyone goes to their jobs
does their training
and get stuck with the unit they're
gonna go and keep in mind at this time
this is when iraq and afghanistan was
popping off and that ultimately was the
reason my father didn't want me to go
and
he was dead on with that
to this
i hate it but that man is always right
to this day everything he tells me i
don't listen
of course
but he is always right
and i'll let you know
but
i kind of stopped i got to start
listening to him because everything he
has told me he has been
dead on
regardless
uh i got attached to an infantry platoon
pretty quickly
i was a field mp that was my job
and uh
i got attached to second battalion third
marines out of k bay in hawaii
and uh
at the time i was in japan
with third marines
and uh
i had a
salty uh
i believe he was a corporal or a
sergeant at the time uh
sergeant leclair at the time
chose
i think 10 marines to go with him
with a on a special little
at the time he called it a special
mission i don't know how special it was
but
he said that
we were going to be seeing combat right
away
and uh
of course my hand shot straight up
and uh
they always tell you in in the marines
never never volunteer for anything but
i gotta say i'm
i'm thankful that i volunteered for this
and uh
to a certain degree because
yeah don't get me wrong i'm i'm a little
i'm a little goofy now a little [ __ ]
up but
i made some of the best relationships of
my life
um
so yeah as i said it's a blur man
we uh from japan we shot over to hawaii
and we got attached with another
probably
another 10 guys
that were
motor t
infantry guys
and uh of course we had com and
a couple docks
but we were part of a
pmt team which is a police mentoring
team
and uh
our mission was to go to a very
dangerous area at the time helen in
helmand province
which at that time was the most
dangerous place in the world
um and we were tasked with
training
and going on missions with
afghans
uh afghan national army which is a a and
afghan highway patrol which is their
form of police
right away
in hawaii
when we got attached to these guys
they let us know that you know
this was
this was for real this was serious and
uh this wasn't just another
you know training evolution or
or just talk or
they weren't gassing us up
uh we were gonna see combat
and they needed us to be ready period
um
so
right away
i was i was always in shape
and i was always an aggressive
individual so
they
they put me on the 50 cal
uh we did a few ranges and i was always
i did very well with the thing and keep
in mind the 50 cal is
not easy to fire or manipulate or
operate period but uh
i did very well with it
um every range that i was on uh
i hit everything i was shooting at oh
keep in mind the rounds like [ __ ]
this big so
but uh
that that meant something to me because
keep in mind i was a field mp i
i was not a machine gunner but they made
me one quick
and uh ever since that moment of going
through those ranges i was
vic one's
machine gunner which we were mostly
running mounted convoys over there um
usually four or five trucks
and each truck has a machine gun but
usually the first truck is always you
know
the scout vehicle or the first one in
like
the first one that's receiving contact
or
getting shot at
is the first truck
um
and yeah that i was the machine gunner
for it
so uh we shot over to afghanistan
and uh
instantly uh well
there's always a uh a party of like five
guys that go there before the team goes
there i think it's like pre-deployment
or i don't know the exact term for it
but uh
the moment they got there
in the area that we were actually going
to be operating in
the ao or area of operation
they got hit by a suicide bomber
this is like within the first week or
two
and uh
we knew it was gonna be real
so
the rest of the guys get over there and
uh
usually when you deploy
you stay on a base and you run a few
operations uh you leave the wire every
once in a while
we lived off of
the base
um
which was scary in its own right because
we were living with the afghans
and it was a very
unsettling feeling
because you really gotta
sleep with one eye open with these guys
um
yes some of them were good to go
but
the other half of them
were somehow related to the taliban
um
and when you're living with these people
that is not something you want to deal
with um
and there was really nothing we could do
about it
regardless
there was always this weird feeling over
there that we were being watched
i i don't know how to explain it but
the hairs on the back of your neck are
always
standing up over there
i don't care who you are it's just this
feeling that someone is watching you
and it's very unsettling
and uh
that's that's how we felt all the time
over there um
regardless so
we had set up this big patrol base and
it was actually in the middle of two
main roads that over there there's
not many roads but
these were
the two paved roads through afghanistan
and uh basically there were main supply
routes msrs
they
basically
any
convoy that went from base to base
carrying goods mail oil weapons
would travel on these roads and the
taliban was absolutely wreaking havoc
with something called ieds
uh
when i was over there there were three
types of ieds maybe four
uh
there were
radio controlled ieds
there was pressure plates
and there was
suicide bombers and then towards the end
of my employment deployment uh they came
up with something called hme
that's what we were calling at the time
basically it's a pressure plate ied that
they stuff with ball bearings
screws
rounds anything metal and these things
get so hot in the ied
when they shoot out
they literally go through
up armor any kind of armor they [ __ ]
buzz right through it and they kill
who's ever in the vehicle
i gotta say and i i don't want to say
that i respected uh the taliban or the
enemy over there but these boys could
fight
uh they adapted to our sops or ttps
sops standing operating procedures uh
ttps or
training techniques and
something else i don't know i've been
out of the game for a little while
but we had to adjust our
tactics our fighting style constantly
for these guys because these guys would
pick up on [ __ ] everything
and
i don't know if that had to do with
taliban being in our camp or just these
guys i mean keep in mind these guys
fought the russians
we start run
something that
shocked me right away and keep mine
we're in a dangerous [ __ ] area we
started going on the offense
which is
i mean
to say the least dangerous
we start
doing mounted convoys up and down these
roads
and
we start
being proactive with these guys i mean
we're fighting every other day
taking contact small arms fire
mortars
sniper fire
um
but we're finding these ieds and
ieds was their
that was their bread and butter that's
how they were that's how they were being
aggressive over there and that's how
they were actually
putting a dent in us
and
i learned quick
about where they put these things
how they installed them
how they operated what to look for and
keep in mind
[ __ ] afghanistan is littered with
trash littered with
uh vehicles that have been blown up uh
old missiles uh mortar shells uh
scud missiles uh
it's it's a it's a boneyard so looking
for these [ __ ] ieds is not
something
that's simple
and the marine corps tried training us
for it but
literally
is
absolutely next to impossible to find
these things
um keep in mind we're in a mountain
convoy going 40 miles an hour down the
road
and
our first line of defense is a mine
roller in front of our vehicle
and then me
up in the gun i have to visually look on
the side of the road and keep in mind
i'm in vic one so i'm the first one
that's calling out these things that we
need to look for
to be proactive to try to stop these
ieds
absolutely blowing us to hell
um
also uh
the the leader for us was uh
his name was captain donner stag and he
was always in my vehicle uh
in the shotgun position because
he would always be on the comms and
reading the blue force tracker and
honestly
he was the guy finding these [ __ ] ids
before i was keep in mind he's in the
vehicle i'm up in the gun he's making me
look like an absolute chump stopping the
vehicle getting us out we're doing five
zero fives and 25s which is
basically over there the first line of
defensive against ieds is zero fives and
twenty fives it's uh
when you stop and get out of the vehicle
open the door
you look down you do a canvas or around
the vehicle that's zero you go five
meters out you go around you're looking
for ids and then you go 25 meters out
that's how we basically see if there's
anything around the vehicle that we're
at
keep in mind always when you get out of
the vehicle you close the door if an id
goes off takes you out you don't want it
blowing up everybody inside so there's
little things like that that
you need to be proactive about
so yeah i mean
we're finding these things we're taking
hits
but
at the end of the day we're being
proactive against the taliban we're
running usually two convoys a day one in
the morning one in the afternoon
and then at night
the lower ranks
private pfc lance corporal we're
standing security over the patrol base
we were in so
we're doing long days
um
it was about that time that
i got into my first serious firefight um
i remember it
it was around 3 a.m
and i was in the rack sleeping
and we started getting mortared
uh when a mortar drops
it's
an absolute sickening sound it's like a
it's like a
hellish whistle almost i don't really
know how to describe it with adjectives
but
you know something big was coming
you can hear it you can feel it you can
sense it and when it hits the ground
everything shakes and it's just what the
[ __ ] going on
first couple hit
instantly when that happens over there
you're trained you're jumping out of the
rack you're throwing your flak on you're
getting your weapon and you run into the
vehicle because you know shit's popping
off
um
our radio started going off that one of
our patrol bases about
i think a couple clicks down uh route
one was getting ambushed
um
these guys planned this [ __ ] out this
was
i've never i played these video games
call of duty all this stuff i've never
seen something like this
so keep in mind i run in my vehicle i
get my 50 up
head space and timing good to go
i'm so focused on getting my weapon
ready and getting everything that we
need to bang it out with these guys i
realize i'm in my boxers i got my boots
on and i got this t-shirt on
[ __ ] it our guys are getting hit we need
to get the [ __ ] out there our trucks are
up
we start blowing out there
and keep in mind i had never been in a
firefight at night before this
uh
where the fastest i've ever gone in the
truck that i'm in
going to this patrol base
radios are going crazy because afghans
can't really speak english so the
interpreter is on the radio blah blah
blah blah we don't understand all we
hear is taliban
and
going into this thing
i
i remember
feeling like this is it
everything i've trained for
is about to
culminate right now
i literally
at that moment seeing i remember just
seeing
tracer rounds going back and forth and
explosions going off
i
i remember
and i'm not trying to be
i'm not trying to exaggerate
i remember
thinking this is what hell looks like
uh
and
weirdly enough
and keep in mind i'm i'm i'm [ __ ] up
but
i got it excited to a certain degree
uh
this was the test
this was
this was there to show me if
if i was ready to call myself a marine
um
we are known
to be the guys that fight
period
and
it's moments like this that you show
your colors
and i remember i racked my 50 back just
put it condition one
and uh
weirdly enough
i thought of my father
i
as a kid growing up
we
always had a song
and uh
it was
it was uh
cats in the cradle by harry chaplin chap
chaplain or something like that
chapin
but it more or less talks about a
father-son story
and uh
i didn't i honestly didn't think i was
coming back out of this
and uh
yeah i thought of him i thought
you know why the [ __ ] did i come over
here
why didn't i listen to him
i got two younger brothers that
i should be
helping
you know grow up
but yeah regardless i remember that that
hit me and uh
i got angry
i got angry
and i was like
these [ __ ] aren't taking me out
who the [ __ ] are they
to take me out
they come over
they fly our [ __ ] planes into our
buildings and kill
thousands of people
and i'm coming over there
and they're they're about to kill me
[ __ ] that
i got
furious
keep in mind i have the biggest machine
gun
the marine corps makes in front of me
i was ready to go
instantly my vehicle starts taking
contact
i'm talking
the guys in my vehicle didn't really see
it but
instantly to the left flank when we got
near this patrol base the whole sky
lights up
all you really see in an instant like
this is muzzle flashes
um
the rounds weren't hitting our vehicle
yet
but instantly i started chirping with
the 50. and these guys were kind of far
out at this point
and
my captain is like what the icardi what
the [ __ ] are you doing and i'm like
sorry are you you [ __ ] kidding me
right now we're getting attacked and he
can't
i don't i don't
i kind of had to
assert to him like like it's time to go
and
uh yeah so he said [ __ ] it too and we
it instantly turned off the road and
went at these guys
here we go
and when you go off road over there
keep in mind this was during the summer
time and uh the sun
bakes these things called wadi's over
there
wadi's i believe i could be wrong don't
kill me on this
are the canals where water runs through
for their plants
so it's like whoops
and in the gun
don't kill me this on on this either but
i didn't i don't believe i had my
no i did i did have my gunner's harness
on but you're supposed to have a
gunner's harness on in the gun
but
we're going over these whoops and i am
absolutely taking a beating
yeah it was scary getting shot at
but my driver keep in mind whenever i
had a driver
they've been hispanic
and both of them savages
they will drive through anything
absolutely [ __ ] anything these guys
are going through it
my drive at the time cervantes he's got
our truck pegged as fast as it's going
to go keep in mind he's got a mind
roller on the front of it which is this
big
plow type thing which is supposed to
take the hit first if we get hit by an
ied
but he's got this thing pegged and we're
going straight at these guys
comms are down
the rest of our trucks
they're
they're taking fire as well and they're
chirping but i don't know what happened
there's this thing called
fog of war
when shit's really popping off
you don't know what's going on and it's
extremely scary
um
regardless the thing that i had at my
disposal was my weapons and i was using
them
i was absolutely blown away anything
that shot at us
but
going through these watties
i'm talking at probably 50 60 miles an
hour
my ammo crate on my 50 cal
blew off
[ __ ]
that's not good
my biggest weapon is down
and at this exact time
we had a vehicle
in front of us
i don't know how many people can say
this but
i saw the whites of this guy's eyes
um
all the other vehicles scattered and
this vehicle was trying to get away
cervantes was right on his my driver was
right on his six i'm talking from me to
you
and i see in the back seat
this giant machine gun
and i see which at the time i believe it
was a pkm
i see the guy in the back mask up
and come out the window
and just start blasting us and his goal
was to come up and hit me
and
yeah he didn't
um i
at that time had my m4 and
i put rounds in the back of the vehicle
and
all i saw was a pink mist
um
regardless the vehicle was still taking
fire
and
i remember
on the
right side of the vehicle it's just
sporadic
and on the left side of the vehicle it
was
a much larger caliber
much
better shots so it was
boom
and one absolutely rocked me
um
hit my kevlar skate my head
knocked me back into the vehicle
and all the guys in the vehicle like
what the [ __ ] just happened and uh and i
yeah i thought i told my i think i'm hit
and uh like where and i was like
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know and
then they like button up the top
and get the [ __ ] down and uh i remember
oddly enough i had a terp interpreter in
the vehicle with us and he's like i
remember him being scared as [ __ ] and
he's
and he's like go back up there and i was
like the
50s down and he tries handing me a
grenade
not the time
regardless that
that was the most intense thing i've
ever done in my
life uh
thank god
none of us were hit we had no casualties
i don't know how
but uh
we did a brief bda
which is like an assessment after a
firefight
and we went back to our patrol base
um
i remember afterwards
after something like that we all clean
weapons
and it's quiet
and everyone's still in
this
odd
shock
um
and then all of a sudden it breaks
and everyone's just like holy [ __ ]
did you see icardi [ __ ] take one and
everyone was just going back and forth
telling their stories about what
happened and it was
almost like a family
i don't i've
there's certain feelings you get over
there that you never feel again
and
that right there i gotta say
i have
never felt the adrenaline from a moment
like that ever again
um
not that i want to
but
god damn
so as i said we uh
worked with a a and ahp
um we had one incident that went down we
got into a
a brief fire fight and
we ended up chasing down a vehicle down
route 606
and we thought
it was just full of taliban fighters but
we ended up ramming it off the road
flipping the vehicle
i think the guys inside died
but we ended up getting
close to
50 60 kilos of raw heroin
and
keep in mind
this is how
the taliban this is the taliban's bread
and butter
they
grow it
in helmand
and they ship it to pakistan
or that's
that's what we learned
and
that's how they get their weapons their
money whatever they need to fight us
regardless
this was very
tense
keep in mind the afghans
i mean i
i know poor
from boston
you know
people don't have money where i'm from
these guys are poor
um
they walk around with their belongings
a weapon
their rags
a toothbrush
which is
odd but every
person that i've searched or
had to
go through their belongings they have a
toothbrush very nasty toothbrush
and a chai cup teacup
that's what
they
own regardless
they are poor
um
when we brought this heroin back to our
patrol base
afghans were laying down their weapons
and stealing the kilos and leaving
which keep in mind i'm 20 21
i have no idea what the [ __ ] is going on
uh
but this
put a very
insecure feeling for us the guys that
we're training fighting with
are quitting
and stealing the heroin that we just got
from the taliban
so i don't know what the [ __ ] going on
there and
basically we all felt extremely uneasy
and we
doubled the security at our patrol base
and
we attempted to hire and do ahp a a and
at that time i could be wrong about this
but
this is when rambo came into the picture
rambo was an ex-mujahideen soldier and i
don't know if you know and keep in mind
i don't know much about the mujahideen
but what i do know is
they were freedom fighters
and they were the ones that fought the
russians
and
some of them went taliban some of them
kind of did their own thing but
these boys could fight
and uh
i had the privilege of meeting one
individual named rambo and
this was the real rambo
this was no hollywood
sylvester stallone
this guy killed people
and
he walked around constantly
probably slept with it
pounds of ammo on his chest for his big
pkm machine gun that he carried with him
everywhere
a very intense individual
they talk about marines having a
thousand-yard stare from firefights they
get into and different things they do
you looked at this guy
and
you know he's been places and he's seen
things
regardless
captain comes in and he asks for
a couple volunteers to go out to a
patrol base
uh down i believe it was route one
and keep in mind whenever they ask for
volunteers to go to a patrol base
hand was always shot right up in the air
because
you were your own boss there was no
higher leadership out there
sergeants corporals lance was privates
ran the show
and that's how it should be
regardless
me and a couple of my buddies went out
this patrol base so there was probably
five six marines maybe less and probably
ten afghans
uh
and rambo
rambo went out there with us
so uh
the first
instant that i had with uh
with rambo
we get out to the patrol base and this
thing was ragtag
basically a couple hesco barriers sand
mounds
it wasn't fit
for a defensive position uh
it needed to be built up
so we brought some more haskell barriers
some constantine wire which is this
badass barbed wire
and uh
a shitload of sandbags
so
we take half the afghans and
we go on a dismounted patrol
through the local town to try to
meet the towns that's the first thing
you do when you get to a new area you go
out to the town you talk to the people
you show respect uh you let them know
that you're gonna be in the area and you
have one goal kill the taliban
and help them
you gotta throughout my life
i stand on you you gotta
give respect to get respect period
and it served me well
regardless
rambo was in charge of the afghans out
there so
i tell the interpreter hey
you guys need to fill a bunch of
sandbags
we're going to go on a patrol build this
[ __ ] up a little bit
and uh we'll be back in a couple hours
so we go on our patrol
nothing really happens we come back and
keep in mind our patrol base is on a
main road i come back and there's
probably
40 cars lined up
stopped at a standstill rambo's on the
main road with his pkm
stopping these guys so they're not going
anywhere
and
everyone's out of their car
fill in sandbags
so
instead of them doing it they pull over
a bunch of civilian afghans and they're
filling the sandbags that's
that's kind of how they do business so
i wasn't really mad at him but you know
whatever
got the job done
who cares
so
next day
we receive a little bit of contact this
is kind of a iffy risky story to tell
about
we receive a little bit of contact some
guys shooting at us
from uh
maybe a football field away
and uh we bunker down
and exchange
a little back
and uh
you can see rambo amping up and he's
really getting aggressive and
he actually
leaves cover
and keep in mind once we
exchange back and forth usually they run
away
uh rambo goes out there
and
actually
shoots one of the guys
goes up to him
and
kicks his weapon away and
puts him down
and we're all like
whoa like
i mean
you can't really do that
and
so i'm yelling at him
what the [ __ ] get back here
he's not really listening
so
we all get back
it settles down then the night
gets there and anytime that we get into
a
serious situation over there
even though these afghans they they
don't have anything
they feel the need
to
eat with us
supply
the meal for the night
um
so they somehow get some kind of meat i
don't know what exactly it was but uh
and uh gnome or bread afghan bread which
actually was pretty good
um
everyone sits in a circle
and
rambo comes around with a basin of water
and washes everyone's hands
he puts the food in the middle
and everyone eats we eat together
i'm 20 21
in the most dangerous part of
afghanistan
or one of them and
me and my boys
my doc doc sanchez
my driver xavier
one of my drivers
and a couple other guys
in the most
dangerous position we could be just
eating with these guys
and uh
we have an interpreter with us
and
i remember
wanting to
keep in mind rambo after we're done
eating he brings out this wicked
huge hookah and over there they they
smoke ash
that's like tobacco to them
and he wants us all to smoke with him
and one of the guys that i was with uh
was no no no no i can't do it or
whatever and rambo looks at him in
disgust and uh
he looks at the interpreter and he's
like
rattles something off to him and the
interpreter laughs and he's like
why you be [ __ ]
we uh we out here we fight together we
we dine together we smoked together and
uh
he was kind of almost offended
and
i told him pay no mind you know
whatever but i countered rambo and i was
like hey guy
why the [ __ ] did you go john wayne
earlier and absolutely disregard
me and not listen at all and uh as i
said before
rambo has this look about him and uh
he gives
and i talk to the interpreter and he
gives me this look and he rattles off
this
10-15 minute story to the interpreter
and the interpreter i'm looking at him
he's just like
and he looks at me and he's like
here we go
so apparently
rambo was a wealthy landowner back
when
the russians came into afghanistan
uh
that's when i believe the taliban
established themselves as a shadow
government over afghanistan
and they were literally going to
everyone's farm or
house that they could occupy and turn
into a defensive position or
just anything that
they could use to benefit them
so they went to rambo's house and i
believe he had daughters and a few wives
according to rambo
they said this is ours now
everything here is ours
and
[Music]
we'll be coming back and i guess rambo
said no
uh according to him and
i guess the taliban came back
shot him
so he he couldn't defend his family
and they raped and killed his family in
front of him
uh
he said to me aft
after this
i kill any taliban that
comes near me period
and
i couldn't
i couldn't question him
that story
resounded in me
i i if i were him i'd feel the same way
yeah
that's that's my rambo story i can't
i'm i'm pretty sure after we left
afghanistan
rambo got killed
but
i need to try to keep that guy's story
alive there's certain individuals that
you meet
that are not
that you need to keep their memory alive
period
and that's one of them
so yeah that's rainbow
as i said uh
my captain and
my driver
took a pretty serious ied hit on a
patrol we went on
and
after that the
that absolutely took all the
wind
out of our sails it was just absolute
they were the spirit of our team
and i know a lot of guys have it much
worse you know when we were over there
ieds were absolutely decimating
people
double amps uh
they were
absolutely creating carnage for our a
lot of marines so
we definitely had didn't have it bad as
a lot of people but
the man i looked up to the most and who
saved my ass on
more times than i can count
took a serious hit by an id and it was
not a
not a good day for us
um
i want to say
kevin donner stag thank you
for everything you did for us over there
um
a day doesn't go by that i don't think
about you
and uh
yeah thank you
you
made us men over there
and you
kept us alive
true definition of a leader
you
embodied that to the fullest
and
we
all recognize that and
i'm sure i'm not the only one that feels
this way
thank you
you